homosexualité et liberté c'est sur ce
thème que plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont défilé cet après-midi à
Paris à l'initiative du Comité d'urgence
antirépression homosexuelle qui
participe à une action internationale
Estelle
[Musique]
g une marche gay très gay ils étai
environ 10000 homosexuels à manif cet
après-midi pour le droit à la différence
et l'abrogation de la loi qui interdit
toutes relations homosexuelles avant 18
ans alors qu'elle autorise les rapports
hétérosexuels dès 15 ans entre ceux qui
manifestent et ceux qui observent
parfois le dialogue s'ébouche pas
travailler dans dans certains domaines
dans certains dans certaines instituts
entre dans certains ministères donc ce
pas normal c'est pour ça qu' qu'on est
obligé de faire des manifestations de
pense pas qu'on réprime les homosexuels
à travaill ah bah si moi je suis
militaire d'actif je suis engagé
infirmier militaire je ne peux on m'
j'ai eu j'étaéis en procès avec la
Marine à cause de ça parce que je j'ais
pas pu continuer ma profession
d'infirmier et même parmi les
manifestants tous n'étaient pas
homosexuels vous êtes dans la
manifestation parce que vous êtes
lesbienne non c'est pour accompagner mon
fils et ses amis pourquoi vous
accompagnez votre fils pour le soutien
parce que je partage ses idées puisque
c'est son pour lui c'est la voix du
bonheur je sais pas pourquoi je ne
serais pas là vous avez compris ça a pas
été trop difficile non pas du tout non
une pour une mère elle le comprend très
vite et je vois pas pourquoi c'est venu
petit à petit je l'ai admis il y a pas
eu de
problème et ainsi jusqu'à Beaubourg pour
faire reculer encore un peu
l'intolérance